l'euro est ce répit offert par le
ministère de l'économie il sera toujours
possible de garder des points de repère
en francs au moins jusqu'au mois de juin
laurent fabius recommande en effet aux
commerçants de maintenir le double
affichage des prix jusqu'à l'été
séverine lebrun christelle jorion payer
rang front seuls quelques irréductibles
le font encore mais penser en feront la
majorité des consommateurs en sont
toujours là même s'ils font tout pour y
échapper
j'ai arrêté de regarder en francs afin
de pouvoir m'en sortir en euros dont
j'ai quelques repères dit france en
france 200 francs les séries ça que je
m'en sors alors évidemment le double
affichage c'est utile surtout pour les
produits qu'on achète plus rarement il
ya des choses que je retiens en euros
mais là j'ai du mal qu'on voit ça
heureusement que ses marques et enfants
moi j'ai compris et oui madame
apprivoiser l'euro peut mettre un
certain temps la moitié des
consommateurs vont probablement réussir
à avoir un système de prix en euros pour
les produits courants en l'espace de
trois mois trois quatre mois
probablement qu'à un tiers vont avoir
besoin de six mois
et puis il va y avoir 10 à 15 % de
consommateurs qui dans un an seront
encore à réfléchir avec des prix en
francs il n'y a pas de secret il va
falloir se créer de nouveaux repères
première leçon pour cette cliente un
caddie plein au supermarché c'est
environ 50 euros